can you name this artist Linda gone for
swim jump on them now swinging off the
rim sounds like jay-z covering Nicki
Minaj is Chumlee right or is Nicki Minaj
just jay-z sped up this conspiracy has
been floating around for years and it's
hilarious you're actually hearing is the
effect of pitch shifting the result of
warping notes voices and other sounds to
make them sound much lower or higher
than normal it's a common tool found in
guitar solos and hip-hop samples even
cartoons but how does it work and why do
people use it
we're here with Diana from physics girl
that we were talking earlier about what
musicians think of pitches as and it's
basically like high note is a high pitch
low no is low pitch so in science we
talk about those notes as low and high
notes as frequencies so check this out
if I sort of slide up I'm not a great
Whistler but if I sort of slide up the
scale like from low pitch to high pitch
what did you notice yeah yeah they got
closer together so like you're seeing
the wavelength which is related to what
we call frequency but it's like shorter
wavelength means higher frequency it
just happens more often that what's
happening when we're pitch shifting
we're just taking that and scrunching
the wavelength yes you would be just
taking your waveform and just like
squeezing it making those Peaks closer
together yeah or further apart if you
pitch shift down before you hear our
original song let's talk about how other
artists have used pitch shifting in
their music when you made thinking
menage sound like JC we slow down the
song to 130 percent which stretched out
the waves to lower the pitch many
artists have used speed altering
techniques to manipulate pitch in their
songs but the bad not really pioneered
this style is one I'm sure you know
songwriter Ross Bagdasarian was
experimenting with the tape recorder in
the late 1950s and discovered a sound
that would define his career he used
this technique to create a duet with
himself in his hit song witch doctor
from 1958 then one day while driving in
Yosemite National Park a chipmunk -
inflamed his car and well it all clicked
he recorded the vocals for Alvin and the
Chipmunks at half the normal speed and
play the tape back at full speed to
create the effect here's how they sound
when you slow a chipmunk song back down
to its original speed where is the
moment we needed them
this technique wasn't new for example it
was used in 1939 to give the Munchkins
of The Wizard of Oz their unique sound
it was also used for cartoon characters
like Tweety Bird pitch shifting wasn't
only used for cartoons in magical
kingdoms Chuck Berry didn't want to
sound like a chipmunk but his record
label did speed up his recording of
sweet little 16 just a little bit so
that he sounded younger when creating
the Beatles Strawberry Fields forever
John Lennon wanted to use parts of take
7 and 26 but due to so much
experimentation in the studio the two
parts were recorded at different tempos
and in different keys producer George
Martin slowed to one take down so that
the two matched you can actually hear
where the splice happens listen to this
shift right before John Lennon says
going to you might have noticed John
Lennon's vocal take was slowed down
which is why it sounds dreamier almost
slurred in more recent years producers
like Kanye and Just Blaze took note from
Ross Bagdasarian and sped up soul and
R&B samples adding a new Alvin and the
Chipmunks kind of flavor to their beats
[Music]
there's another way to affect pitch
without adjusting the timing at all
artists like Jimi Hendrix use guitar
pedals to digitally affect the pitch in
real time in his song Purple Haze he
played the guitar through a pedal called
the Octavia which electronically doubles
the frequency of the notes that are
being played so that they sound an
octave higher
in more recent years Jack white used a
guitar pedal called the digitech whammy
to do the exact opposite because the
white stripes lacked a bass guitarist
Jack white pitched down his guitar to
sound like a bass in the song seven
nation army artists have also used pitch
shifting to fix mistakes auto-tune was
invented in 1997 to hide studio errors
notes that were sung a bit off were no
longer going to ruin a take producers
were able to shift frequencies of notes
to make everything sound perfectly in
tune but then on October 19th 1998 this
happened auto-tune evolved from the
audio version of white out into an
instrument itself cher didn't use it to
cover up her mistakes instead she used
it as a vocal effect some pure is still
derided as a crutch or a gimmick while
others like Radiohead Lil Wayne and
t-pain saw it as another tool to make
something unique
when COTC Dino claimed that Justin
Bieber and Skrillex his song sorry
infringed on the copyright of her song
ringing the bell Skrillex took to
Twitter to show that he didn't steal the
song but actually use a pitch shifting
to create the songs course in a way that
made it a very close match I'll take
this pitch up in recent years there has
been a wave of courses that featured
vocals with race pitches and fragmented
parts with producers contorting the
human voice into catchy but alien
sounding hooks pink Major Lazer's leaned
on
or Skrillex Diplo and Bieber's where are
you now what do you think you can do
with a pitch shift song maybe taking a
sample of someone talking because that's
there are pitches if you really examine
what if every element of the song is
pitch shifted in some way I feel like
it's gonna sound really trippy because
like everything every part of like
there's nothing familiar in there
anymore because everything has been out
to be is good this is the trippy is
great yeah I hope it sounds trippy I
have a clip of Diana speaking right now
so play I'm Diana from physics girl and
you're watching sound field we should
use her definition of pitch we can start
the track just to give the clips of
context but then gradually pitch shift
it are so pitch is the frequency of the
sound wave which tells you how often
your wave is moving back and forth your
wave is moving your wave is moving back
and forth back and forth back and forth
back and forth back and forth back and
forth okay we have a track
pitch is the frequency of the sound wave
which tells you how often your wave is
moving nothing for the flavours living
[Music]
as for jay-z and Nicki Minaj well Jay is
the one that wrote death an auto-tune to
protest all this pitch shifting but then
again if he's Nikki's ghost rapper
wouldn't that be the right move to throw
us all off we just want to give a shout
out to that's Te'o for taking the beat
we did on our trap episode and remix in
it and wrapping it check it out and if I
make a Billy give it to the kids no camp
[ __ ] this gamma [ __ ] overflow on
tempeh if I'm getting hungry shove a
trap bar rep snack but then there's got
me all TPS too and I'm gonna make it
happen because the viewers where you
thank you
[Music]